[Music]
you've enjoyed it for years and shows
like Curb Your Enthusiasm blackish and
now you can enjoy her first Netflix
comedy special Wanda Sykes not normal
available for streaming right now was
released a couple weeks ago so get on it
while the getting is good good to see
you Wanda Sykes network so what is it
like to get out in front of people and
just do do that make people laugh I mean
what in the world is that I I did
stand-up back in college yeah and I
there's no feeling quite like it even
with what I've been fortunate to do
afterwards it's just a tremendous high
you know to be able to stand on stage
and say something to a bunch of
strangers and make them laugh you know
to be able to adjust their mood right so
yeah it's I mean it's I got no it
definitely is a gift I don't think it's
something that can be taught right you
know but yeah it just feels great what
were you doing before you got into um I
work for NSA National Security Agency
yeah you know really are you allowed to
talk about what you did for the enemy no
it's it's been so long ago that anything
that I know that's a was top secret it's
it's probably public knowledge now she's
probably on Wikipedia I'm sure you had
clearance back in the top secret
security clearance yeah come on now no
I'm serious yeah so were there I mean
were there moments like dicey moments
for you like where you made national
security decisions I worked in an office
I wasn't out in the field no doing
anything you know doing hanging passes
and stuff but no I don't know there was
no I was in office okay
and I basically bought stuff I was a
contracting specialist but you had class
but you needed clearance I was by some
pretty serious stuff
so we're there just like moments where
you're in the NSA and people like you're
funny you shouldn't be doing NSA you
should actually be doing stand-up comedy
something like that um I think I said it
to myself I mean I wasn't in any
environment that I was in be it like
school or work I would always make my
co-workers laugh
and then you know and they would say you
know you should be on stage you should
be on stage and and when I was at the
NSA I just knew that I was like this
cannot be my life for the next 20 years
and then you retire and no I can't do
this what was your big break you
remember what would you turn your back
well I mean just getting started just to
it was a it was a talent show that a
radio station was having and I comedy
was a category I was like okay you know
let me try it out I actually just wrote
some jokes okay while I was sitting at
my desk at NSA yes all government time
yeah you know when I went down there and
try it out and he said great put me on
the show okay yeah and then oh if you
want off I was only one but my big break
was definitely Chris Rock Show
Rock Show that show was so damn funny
mm-hm and it was it was groundbreaking I
really do believe that just yeah did
what Chris was doing and some of the the
bits III I do remember one time I
actually was in the studio audience for
one of them cuz you shot it in New York
City yeah is there I loved it I loved
everything about you did it was Chris
Rock tried out for four and I'm in the
middle of a hot flash you see me do you
need some travel with a fan but I didn't
bring it out look at me like Mike Tyson
look at this Jesus you got a case you
step in with a fan here we go the camp
was like right on my face we're we're
we're
rounds were between rounds right here in
the recharge no speaking of not normal
is this not normal for us the hot flash
menopause is not normal
we've never had a menopausal moment on
the Richard show before but this is life
[Laughter]
all right let's do it this happen on the
live Jefferson broadcast as well you
know what I literally had ice packs
wrapped around my back when I did the
Jefferson did you really I did under
that wardrobe I had ice packs because I
was like I can't this cannot happen
Dornan right well you were in the fan
we're here in the fan right now yeah so
that was amazing what was that like to
step back in time and that's Norman
friggin Lear we said right there the
greater of all in the family which
before all that and then a live
performance of The Jeffersons with Jamie
Foxx yes in the in the Sherman Helmsley
role and you were playing Weezy so what
what in the world that was that like
that was a that was a dream you know
dream come true really I mean because
whenever someone asked me what type of
show do you want to do I always say I
want to do like a Norman Lear type show
yeah yeah I'm actually doing I'm
actually doing yeah not just one - I was
in the only family - yes I'm doing yeah
I'm - Norman Lear shows like my favorite
shows and and then with this casts I'm
surrounded by Oscar winners you know it
was it was nice and Norman Lear is alive
and kickin it and he was there every day
and you know rehearsals notes and stuff
so it was amazing and Jennifer Hudson
killed moving on up she killed it like I
would I would pay to see that again
yeah she was unbelievable here's a funny
story about that one um okay the hot
flash past when we were Hurst the the
original blocking of the opening of The
Jeffersons yeah it was Jennifer sings
the song and then she enters the
elevator and then we walk out and start
the scene and
Harry don't rehearsal Jackie looked at
me she's like you know we gonna be
standing here for a long time waiting
for them people don't applaud for it cuz
Jennifer's gonna tear this up you know
that you know we gonna be standing here
forever I was like no I think I think
it'd be okay sure enough when we did a
rehearsal with with Jennifer mm-hmm it
was nuts the people went I mean they was
going nuts so I was like okay you're
right so that's why they changed it was
like okay you know what we're gonna take
a commercial break because we can't walk
out after that yeah that's not happening
people missed the whole half of the show
every time I see Jennifer Hudson do
anything I think how the hell did she
not win American Idol like how the hell
did that happen right I don't even know
I don't even know who won can you be
like yeah look that up that's what the
Internet's for she finished like even
like fifth or sixth right I mean like
seventh seventh there were six people
considered better than Jennifer Hudson
Fantasia one that year one that season
three Fantasia one is that exact yeah is
that acceptable Fantasia is great but
but J had all day come on come on so not
normal
wanda sykes not normal the Netflix
comedy special do you want to chime in
on the whole subject of the topic du
jour in the sports world today of the
Women's World Cup where they scored 13
times and they've been criticized for
celebrating anything like that because
that's not normal uh it was it was zero
three at the half right absolutely so I
have it on I'm like getting dressed cuz
I had to do something I have it on and
I'm watching within five minutes they
scored three more goals right yes and as
I'm tweeting like oh my god I can't
believe they just scored three goals and
go I was old but I can't even finish the
story and they just scored another goal
I thought it was amazing I mean people
what it's all about oh then you know
poor sportsmanship no look it's the
World Cup they came to play you don't
you know half-step it or you know you
know you came to play and think about
all the work I mean their parents and
everything game at the game all this
training you want to see
kids score a goal you know my kids
we can walk to the soccer field where
they play right yeah if I get there and
I'm staying out there for an hour
and they don't score on the walk home
I'm looking at my son like really he was
open you could really
what's all this pants and stuff what's
that shoe put the ball in the net put
the ball in the net I want to see that I
mean I'm a soccer game chicken you can
watch it for four hours
right and nobody scores and they got to
go to the to the shootout okay come on I
say score go for it girls I was thinking
the same thing it's just like how many
times have I heard people complain in
this country outside of this country
nobody really complains very much about
the sport but we're like okay so it's
one nothing to one now we got 13 on the
board like 13 goals and now we're I have
no problem with them scoring a lot of
people have had problems with the
celebrating like after you're up ten
nothing you're 11 nothing why are you
celebrating like it's like the world's
coming to an end you know it's rare when
you score in soccer I celebrate I wanted
to see some back flips your problems was
the the lack of maybe gymnastics in the
celebration yeah I forgot her name she
scored and she didn't even know how to
celebrate she just there's something
goofy like like she's like boy practice
is celebration get it together
you know but she was just so amazed that
did this shocked that she scored yeah I
know III really didn't have any problem
with it at all but so many people
problem at all right so some of the
subjects that you you you talked about
in in your stand-up act some of it has
to do with with parenting right and kids
would you agree that kids who are not up
because I have three they're ten eight
and five okay right but they ruin a lot
of stuff oh absolutely
right they do they I mean you're you
know it's a game changer right oh yeah
so for good good right that doesn't go
away you know it's not like oh you know
when they get to college you get you
life back no you don't mmm it's gone
your life is gone this this is it male
but and I'm not saying that that's a
that's a good thing you're sure I'm sure
having kids probably extended my life
you know without kids
I probably they found me dead in a Vegas
hotel by now you know make you go home
you have to go home right keep they keep
you out of trouble you know and it's I
don't know I like you said you love it
I'm loving it but I know it's not the
life that I had right at all you can't
fly off anywhere you can't just do
whatever the heck you want to do I know
I know Wow and then you're at soccer
games you're standing at a soccer game
how are you as a soccer parent are you
barking on the sideline do you go after
the refs and the officer or any any type
of your work any of these games it
hasn't gotten that serious yet okay it
hasn't gotten us seriously what about
other parents when they get serious then
then you've given me permission to start
barking off I love that yeah I I don't
want to be the first one but as soon as
I see someone going on my oh we're doing
this okay just don't open the door
because right off the field yeah then
you'll walk through your walk through so
we had a subject here a conversation and
you obviously know what is normal or
what's not normal we had a conversation
about air travel and I'd love for you to
chime in on it it kind of went a little
viral the subject matter of being in the
middle seat and if that person deserves
both arm rests because they're sitting
in the middle seat do you have any
stance on this subject at all Wanda
Sykes I know I'm throwing something
completely off the wall at you I know
about this because you know I still I
still travel coach sometimes you know if
it's a short flight hmm
and I guess I mean it depends on the
size of the person mm-hmm if if if I'm
older than the person next to me this is
my damn armrest you sit you yeah this is
my armrest both of them you taken I'm
taking both of them hmm but if it's an
older person
or if it's like just a bigger person and
they're uncomfortable then I'll go ahead
and give them out I'll go ahead and go
this way and let them have it okay yeah
but other than that are you staking out
your you're staking out your space when
you first sit down yes that's what I
would do that's what I do
yeah you sit you stake out your space
and then whoever sits down next to you
you calibrate your decision
exactly okay yeah what is your pet peeve
with traveling on Airlines feet I don't
want to see your feet I don't wanna see
your feet god bless you oh I don't want
to see some hot toes wiggling from from
from behind my seat if I'm sitting it
and also I see a hot foot right here
what are you gonna do what do you do
yeah look yeah I give him the look I
give him a look like you know I turn
around like uh you would get your hot
feet did you see the video this little
kiss yes that's what I so what happens
if the look doesn't work though
see to me I'm the same way as you right
I don't this is not your living room
we're all in the same tube here right
okay right so the living room rules
don't apply your room is now my room my
room is your room right I don't want to
be put in the position of wondering if
your feet are properly cleansed or
anything like that exactly that is my
pet peeve - yeah look doesn't work then
I'm stuffing everything back here you
gonna get the air the magazines
everything everything is just this is
just pushing your foot off and
everything going back there
fantastic I'm a big fan of yours Wanda I
really appreciate you coming on this
show you know and congrats on the on the
Netflix special that's on that shot in
in in New York City and yeah and we'll
have next time you come here and we'll
have everything set up all of the fan at
the ready just in case you know
you could put some air conditioning in
these seats is that what yeah cuz the
seats come up a little high and it
creates a little bit of a hot boxes I
understand what you're saying
but thanks for coming out Wanda I'm a
big fan and Wanda Sykes
I am Wanda Sykes on Twitter and also on
Instagram the one-hour special available
for streaming right now called Wanda
Sykes not normal it's on Netflix for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app